yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby guys
I'm so
glad we were talking we were having
football football Monday we were talking
about football talking about fighting
and I'm doing the fans uh favor here by
not bringing it on the show because your
first question was Dallas play went no
they had a buy cool Sam Fran though I
watched that game I will they play
tonight you know what let's not talk
football in the Pod I figure out I got a
lot of I got a lot of things I say
that's you in general right no no no no
I'm I'm Shu I'm pretty learned and like
and I got some I got tricks up my sleeve
that's what we know about me Rogan was
not impressed with your boxing on fight
campaign Eddie wanted to make sure that
we saw your box see me moving my uh my
feet and stuff I know I saw it dude I
had a good view of it we had a good time
in the companion yeah it was good you
let Eddie drink tequila he turns in the
[__] monster gin great he's like a
gremlin after midnight yeah it was it
was fun always good to hang in and out
though in and out well you and I I
remember I had a 7:30 flight or a 445
but now here's what happens when you
have a baby you want to go home and see
the baby before they go to sleep badly
but I thought we were on the same 7:30
flight originally and switch literally
goes should I try to make the 445 ago
yeah and you we had 30 minutes to get to
the 30 minutes he but when he went
through TSA security he didn't have a a
ticket on the flight correct and we made
it yeah pulled it off and and I don't
know if you guys know this but I was
doing I decided to eat some mushroom
chocolate I decided to have just a
little M I'm going to have a you guys
are people are smoking weed drinking I
I've suffered from peer pressure so I
was like no one peer pressure do this is
my thing on this you're 50 years old
dude 56 you're 56 yeah so I was like y
Brian must do shrooms all the time this
is fine it's not like you're some young
kid who doesn't know podcast but I
wanted to be in the cool Club so I said
but no one else is doing it well I made
my own cool Club then and I okay onean
membership one man it was a oneman
membership it's your own thing it's my
own thing okay but I don't know why I
did it I don't know why I decid suddenly
hey if everybody else is going to alter
their Consciousness you were smoking a
cigar I was like that doesn't alter my
conscious was too early it was too early
to drink whiskey so I was like I'm going
to do psychedelics because maybe I'll
see something will open a portal well
what happens in those
sitations is that it hits you like later
on and I was on the plane edible yeah
and I was on the plane well my stomach
started really hurting I don't know what
it's in those [__] like my stomach
was hurting up here psychedelic
mushrooms yeah I had psychedelic
problems fungus I got they told me to
move my
seat and I I that was you would have
thought I was going to have to cross the
Sahara I was like what I have to get out
of this seat and then go to another seat
a window seat but even on companion a
little quiet like when we got down like
you barely it started hitting me it
started to hit me we've been podcasting
for over 10,000 hours yeah and you still
I took too many at this level I I
thought I was taking a little I thought
it was going to be a little like that
but there's no such thing for me because
what happens is all of a sudden I'm like
I like Eddie was talking started
freaking me out because I couldn't
follow what he was saying and I was like
Eddie you're talking too much about wigs
or whatever it is and I'm going to lose
my mind 30 minutes on wgs yeah yeah
because I was trip I started a trip and
then it would go then I come back to
normal life I would tripping in and out
so then then I have to move seats which
is a catastrophe it's a catastrophe I'm
saying sorry to everybody I don't know
what's going on I get in my seat two
rows I saw you moveing it was two rows
it was two rows it two rows here to
there I was like all right like sorry to
everyone on the plane but then he text
me go he goes I'm In First Class enjoy
standard peasant I'm like all right yeah
and by the way I was only two seats and
it wasn't two seats in front of me and
the seats were nothing cuz we had get
these flights in a hurry so so then I'm
sitting there and I'm and now I'm at the
window and I'm in first class and
there's a guy next to me and I have I
bought three bags of cheesy popcorn not
one not two but three I don't even know
why I did that I don't know why I did
that you know what I did I went what if
this is what I said panick I panicked
cuz I go I should buy two back what if
Brendan takes one he could take one from
me I don't like popcorn cuz I I knew you
were hungry yeah so I felt like I was
going to have to share my [__]
popcorn with you so now I go I'll take
three bags but there was no time to then
I get to the [__] thing and I even
asked for popcorn you do you want some
popcorn no I hate popcorn I know now I
have three bags of popcorn that I I
can't put in my bag because I'm it's too
much so now I'm holding three bags I
come on blah blah blah now I didn't tell
you this part I'm sitting there and the
guy's next to me and I don't know how
I'm going to get the popcorn in my hand
and into my mouth that's that's already
a [__] problem so I start too old for
this right I start doing this are you
rushing for a and I'm eating it like
this so it doesn't
spill but I'm facing the window cuz I
think he's watching me cuz the one thing
my wife will divorce me over is if I
lick my fingers and when I put my
fingers in cheesy poporn you lick your
fingers lick my she goes that is the
most that's the worst thing I've ever
seen it's a disaster for her and I
thought he was going to feel the same
way so I was going like this he probably
did it was it [__] me up dude and then
I started texting you weird [__] like
I'm tripping I'm having trouble sitting
playing I was ago my service is bad yeah
you didn't respond to me I pretend Serv
somebody talk to me I was watching the
football G none of you guys I was
texting Rogan you and Eddie no one
respond nobody nobody [__] respond
that's my favorite when you send
something to the group chat and nobody
responds I'm like he feels this yeah you
[__] you kept texting
yeah I'm tripping somebody normal
[__] but when you're doing the
mushroom notice I don't get really faded
on pods anymore it's very I barely
drinka I have a little bit of whiskey
and then especially when I do R I love
cigars there only there really I do the
cigar do a little whiskey I'm chilling
dude for 3 hours got to drop some fight
knowledge I don't want to be all weird
and I'm bragging I'm like I I kept
hitting Bren I go you [__] meat pie
you peasant [__] you're in seat you
know and I'm in seat
five like I'd want something they just
bumped me up because I had the points
and guy and that's what it was say he
goes uh you Mr G I was like
oh you're in first class oh no I almost
gave my seat up I have another
confession you text me when you landed
and I just pretend I was
asleep
wow wow hey we saw our boy I did CU I
didn't want to go anywhere I was just in
my hotel cozied up and he texted me yep
and I was like nah the the the good news
is by the time I got I landed most of
the mushrooms had worn off and I was we
we both proved to each other that we're
gay men because we oh this boy was fun
we ran into Brandon brand who is the
owner of House of macademia who was our
sponsor still is and still is and and
Brandon Brandon the owner he from South
Africa South Africa and he is here I'm
going to say it he's delicious gorgeous
delicious I'm going take a step up like
he walked up I saw Brian right when we
got off the I see Brian talk to I was
like he's like 33 dressed well he had
like this coat and then this deep V cut
with all all like muscular long hair ing
blue eyes yeah yeah like really
goodlooking and I I figured you know as
a fan or something I walk up and he said
where he from I was like oh you lit up
too in my head I'm like this dude is
breathtaking he's he's bre there he is
there he is he's breathtaking I'm I'm
telling you man it's not easy to please
me but I was like no as and then you lit
up like a Christmas your face you just
went High well no because the house of
macadamia you know we do have this deal
with him so I was like what's up yeah
and you were like Jesus he Jesus and
then we were talking then he was like ah
it's supposed to be my buddy I'm at this
turmo it's all good what do you you need
a ride or and he was like sure like I
don't even have a car man we can figure
it out though I'll buy one you want to
hang out yeah I like you want to what do
you want to do both all to your house as
he walked away and then I's leaving like
y I'll suck yall as he walked away Bren
and I both both watched him walk away
like We w we were looking at his back
and his round Apple Bottom long South
African legs and the piercing blue eyes
and then his style style you know he's
loaded he's got money you're like what
the [__] is going on here is this how
you make Macadamia milk basically well I
told him I said dude you've given us
literally a gallon of macadamia
nut let me yeah fill you up we both as
he walked away we said with happiness
yeah as he walked away we said it again
like a couple of gay men we were like
this we I looked at Bri I went is that
the best looking dude you've ever seen
yeah yeah and we and we and we lingered
on him as he walked away we lingered and
then a dude comes up to us like
interrupts our we're both like this ah
and then a guy goes excuse me we turn
around and he's tall redhead
big yeah he go he go I'm he goes I'm a
big fan and he goes like that and Brenda
goes God that was awful on my
eyes but he wasn't even bad looking was
just a big he wasn't bad but you go from
[__] Prince Charming in South Africa to
this warlock it was like someone put a
bright light in Mye went ah what's up
man you were like oh God don't don't
look like that that's what you said as
he walked away you go don't look like
that God we're so superficial and gay
it's crazy that guy he got me off guard
man yeah we're that guy caught me off
guard we're a couple of gays be let's
take a little break man cuz you know how
tough it is to go cold turkey yeah it's
really hard turkeys for sandwiches dude
but there's a better way to break your
bad habits we're talking about some
we're not talking about some weird
Voodoo that you get from your crazy
neighbor on how to break this weird
habit we're talking about our sponsor
fume dude well it's it's an
award-winning flavored air device yep
they look at the pr a different way not
everything in a bad habit is wrong it's
just the bad stuff all right why not
just remove the bad from your habit well
let's talk about fume which uses
flavored air it's completely natural
uses delicious flavors okay so flavors
are intense daddy they're intense oh
they're nice so if you have trouble
stopping uh a certain habit that you're
not happy with fume is here to help okay
I like the orange vanilla myself that's
what I like to use here stopping is
something we all put off because it's
freaking hard but switching to fume is
easy enjoyable and even fun fume has
served over 150,000 customers has
thousands of success stories there's no
reason that can't be you join fume in
accelerating Humanity's breakup from
destructive Habits by picking up the
Journey pack today that's right and by
the way fume is spelled Fu M so Tri fume
t r y Fu
m.com and use the Cod of fighter to save
10% off when you get the journey pack
today that's T try
f.com and use code fighter to save an
additional 10% off your order today fume
tasty few dude look with everything
going on dude I'll tell you right now
I'm into gold I'm like pirate dude with
everything going on in the world talking
about war inflation the economy right
now could be the best time ever to
diversify your money and savings with
the precious medals like gold and silver
I bought some precious medals myself I
got them from the top rated company
talking about gold Co well they're
a-rated plus by the Better Business
Bureau they've earned 5,000 F star
reviews and they're seven time Inc 5000
winner um and that's just mentioning a
few of their their accomplishment so
right now the fighter and kid listeners
they're offering up to $10,000 in bonus
silver while supplies last go to Gold
co.com Fighter learnmore um and there it
is so you want to diversify your money
your portfolio like Scrooge McDuck man
get the
gold.com fighter gold code.com fighter
get your gold now are you happy you
don't you don't owe me money the pirate
hey I the pirate pirate is uh Nick Davis
is that who you found at the airport uh
I wish he looked that like he's I wish
he was that hot he lives in Middle Earth
or in the middle of the magical forest
either way in a tree in a large tree
dude I'll jump on a ship though that was
your pirate captain now how now how good
a friend am I I knew I was up a grand
and I still doubled down on the other
bet just to be cool it's a good bet
though M CH via submission even though
volkanovski's never been finished never
been submitted it's not though that's me
being like let's be cool is that right
yeah yes okay you don't think I knew
that I wish I had I wish I had said two
things I knew or I I suspected one was
he was going to use a front kick up the
middle and I didn't say it and two was
he was going to bang it out not wrestle
I always feel like wrestlers like I say
banged it out I would say banged it out
you can't say bang it out don't say bang
out no matter what don't say he banged
him out no matter what when it comes to
fighting but then also even if we could
they banged him out you wouldn't label
that fight as a bang out fight the whole
thing's nasty and it's not true
factual oh one thing I wish I said is I
he really banged him
out hey man never say that no don't say
banged out okay two dudes fighting sorry
I had I was I know you're gay gay I had
some gay on the brain oh man hopefully
mchv bangs him out bangs him out what
what wait what do you want a gallon of
macadamia nut
too oh [__] yeah you wouldn't say bang
him out though right yeah well I I I
went a little hard on
chamaya no you no fine he didn't he
didn't look he didn't he did break his
hand yeah but even with that like he
didn't look like he the hype on him is
so incredible and you got and I'm I'm
all up on it Jing nuts yep he's got all
the wrestling he's got all the wrestling
you got to give it up to he took K uh he
took Usman he did get on top of him he
did ride him he did take him down 108
first round yeah everyone had 108 except
for one weird Jam's wrestling is is no
joke I think you know Usman is say what
you will he's a hell of a wrestler right
yeah he's not Hamot level I thought it
was funny when like he stopped his T I'm
like there's levels to this game you
think the first shot is the that's a
setup you [__] idiot no don't call me
that right you like go stuffed this shot
I went no no [__] off heyy tell us how
they're going to bang it out [__]
idiot no listen you piece of [__] listen
listen you piece of [__] what I'm saying
these boys are banging them out stuff
take down what I'm saying is that it's
going to be very interesting to see what
happens with kamat and you know who no
who there's a few guys you could fight
Bo nickel well that's not happening
anytime soon no who does he who do fight
now he goes right to strickly yeah Dana
said he the guaranteed tile shot which I
don't agree with why this is hard say
because I love ham why don't you agree
with it he doesn't have the the the
pedigree he doesn't have the background
his who his level of difficulty to get
the tile shot is is trash should fight
he fought two welterweights one on 10day
notice he fought Uh Kevin Holland on a
thre minute notice yeah correct and then
so his best wins over merart that gets
you a title shot or look at drias dupes
who has beat the who's who he beat
Robert Whitaker yeah the toughest test
in midweight division Robert Whitaker
he's not hurt not anymore he's not hurt
his issue is he turned down the title
fight against Strickland and that is the
curse of all
curses we don't know they say because
his shoulder maybe his Israel you mean
Israel yeah he turned down what I say oh
my bad yeah he turned it turned down the
Izzy fight and remember Strickland
filled in for him got it and once you
once Dana thinks like here's your shot
and you turn it down he's like say less
you're going to get banged out and then
he goes on to somebody else well well so
he but his level of difficulty his
strength of schedule is so much better
than everybody else is he should have
the title shot it's stupid yes
um but he could fight what about PA
Costa what's going to happen with that
will that the UFC can't count on him
that's the other thing they can't count
on him no think many fights he's falling
out or Miss weight or this or that so
again once you become a little flaky
then the UFC also is like we well we
can't depend on that so then you don't
get big fights
O So for dupes it's like like he it's he
should be fighting for the title and
he's a
[__] I wonder how long it takes
for com out's hand to heal how bad the
break that's assuming it's broke that's
assuming do we have any info on that I
look for the update nothing so far
that's assuming it's broke
yeah um you also the other thing you got
to remember too is the the urban myth is
urban legend is
can't come to the states and fight so
you're going to ask your champ who's
Strickland who beat Izzy beat the breaks
off him you're going to ask the guy who
has the belt to bend the knee go to his
home country and fight cuz this guy what
are we doing yeah well it's it's it's
just what people want to see right they
want to see if he's for real but I don't
know if they do so you want to see I
don't if they do though they do he's
massive massive massive in in the in the
Arab world everywhere everywhere he
can't in in the Arab world he's he's Tom
Brady he can't walk anywhere really no
oh my God he's massive wow I forget
where they where he was at they might
have been New York they showed a video
of him shut down the street he's massive
dude okay then that's one of the reasons
why they pushing him there it is right
yeah but St International Strickland's
massive in America now yeah people love
Strickland strick want to put that
American versus you know whatever I mean
I don't
know I I I I I I just don't understand
how if you're hamza's team and Dana goes
pitch me on why he deserves a title shot
go will he beat two welterweights that's
not I agree with you I I agree with you
so why should he have dupes he just beat
Robert Whitaker who's a legit
middleweight no I mean listen it's a
hardell I agree I think he's going to
have a really hard time at 85 I really
do I think he's going to be champ
eventually I'm saying right now the 85
pound I I bet all day I I'll bet you I
me we're going to forget but no I don't
I just think he has the skill to do it
I'm telling you he he that's the word
right you're going on the word right I'm
going off the word and yeah people are
like this guy a monster monster
yeah but right now what we've seen no
not it's too much too soon I don't think
they I think they're going to do
themselves a disservice make him champ
now because he's not going to be there
very long see here's here's how I feel
about jayv oh this is the UK where he
shut down my bad I said New York this is
what I I I this is why I disagree with
him being champion at least for now I
don't think he has the Striking I think
he gets hit and I think when he gets hit
by bigger guys because he got he got hit
by Usman he got hit by Burns I think
chamaya gets hit and I don't I don't
know that his striking is on the level I
know I don't think his striking is on
the level that his wrestling is bub and
I think he's going to get caught but
neither is B Nicholls and and and and to
your stupid point Iz he grappling is not
up to the other guys but if you're an
outlier in one thing you can force your
will you can if you're such an outlier
in one thing hamza's thing's not
striking cuz his grappling so look at
khabib's not good but his grappling so
good makev striking is good it's not
world class it's good but his his gra
thing is M get hit his grappling so good
Cham gets hit he gets hit and and I
think with those bigger guys you know
depends if he if he can take him down
and get and get him out of there if he
can take him down well he's he can take
anybody down b n might be a different
animal but for the most part all those
top guys he can take down guant he's
always been hard to take down guys like
that guarantee you can take him down
yes that's his thing he's an out I'm
gonna again I'm gonna play devil's
advocate he may take him down then what
then what like I don't know that he has
the finishing that some of these other
guys said wrestling's great I don't know
that his finishing is the world class
level that it needs to be in terms of
right like I just didn't see that no man
he put a clinic 108 in that first round
then broke his hand definitely yeah he
he put He put a anacon choke on Kevin
Holland in 30 seconds you know how hard
that is do and you know what Kevin
Holland is a black belt you stupid [__]
well listen you stupid [__] I'm talking
about I'm talking about [__] dealing
with real there's other guys were
different different levels
who what grappling what grappling what
black belts I think there are guys who
are better at standing up and
neutralizing we're not talking about
that see that's a different argument
yeah we're talking you said when it
comes to black belts on ground so I I've
seen with with Kevin Holland who again
he may be a black Bel not known for his
grappling Travis L doesn't matter I mean
Kevin Holland in fact bad example
because Kevin Holland Kevin Holland was
literally fighting and looking at Daniel
Corman and saying you got to teach me
wrestling we be you're talking about two
separate things look at my face but no
Jiu-Jitsu and wrestling are two separate
components of mixed martial arts no this
is such a bad grappling bro no they're
not the same thing one's wrestling one's
grappling I was a wrestler yeah I know
but you got to realize
you got to realize Kevin H's a Travis
lutter black belt that's insane highle
black belt got Dar in 40 seconds but
again to my point I'm going to wait how
those top five guys who at that level
can compete with him on the ground with
chamv when it comes to
grappling bring up bring up uh the
Whitaker comes to
mind and Whitaker Whitaker's black belt
grappling yeah workers grappling is
substantial it's good I think PA Costa's
grappling is going to be a [__] for him
oh because he because he did so well
against luk
rockold that's true he didn't do it so
well but Luke Rocko is a different
animal when it comes to grappling his
grappling is ridiculous he very good
yeah
so yeah I'm I'm just not on the I'm not
on the chamaya train Bubba I'm just not
on 85 I think chamaya I think Cham has
prob guys in the Bigg as far as straight
Jiu-Jitsu vtori kire Whitaker polies
they're all big they better at something
else and they might be bigger but when
it comes to straight up wrestling he's
taking all of them down they're all
they're all really big they're so much
bigger and they're so much stronger I
don't know I think he has his hand and
if size was the only thing that counted
he'd be screwed but I think it's not no
it's not but he has his he has his hands
full yeah is he a small 85 or normal 85
he's a normal cuz dup's massive Whitaker
used to fight at 70 Jer caner massive
used to fight at heavyweight vtori
thicker but short po Costa
massive yeah I'm very intrigued I'm
intrigued now Paul Craig could give him
some frits on the
ground I've just not yeah I guess I
guess if he can rely on his wrestling
but I don't know if he can I don't think
he relies on his wrestling at 85 I just
don't I think those guys figure that out
I I I just think those guys make him pay
every time he comes in and he tends to
also so then you don't think Bo Nichols
will be
champ well I think Bo Nichols wrestling
is g to be such a problem for
everyone and you don't think
H I don't think kza I don't know know
he's a national champion in Sweden
there's a big difference still so I
don't think kamat's wrestling is on the
level of a bon nickel right so I think
those are two different conversations
different animal again I'm not but I
don't really know and the reason I don't
really know is because we haven't seen
him fight a middle we haven't seen him
fight a big time middleweight so I'm
waiting and I'm still intrigued because
he broke his hand still won B isn't it
weird that you're I'm I'm on the same
boat as you going we haven't seen him
beat a big middleweight we haven't seen
him be yeah and then he's going to fight
for a title there you go isn't that
strange yes cuz are we going to wait
till find out if he can handle those big
middleweights when he's Champion you
never see anything like coulde more I
don't I don't but he but again it's the
UFC It's Entertainment people want to
see him
so you know and he is
undefeated yeah he's a monster
monster and the word is when it comes to
his training camp and stuff like that
the people he's beaten I heard we
haven't seen a thing yeah tip of the
iceberg same thing he said about Mev
like there's a reason there's hype oh
yeah there reason why I'm on his nuts
and by the way I I will again say that
dominating boont on the ground like that
and he dominated him is no easy task
it's round yeah that's not easy and then
if you didn't break his hand who knows
correct he's probably not forced to
stand with him he probably takes him
down and gets a finish but we don't know
he broke his hand yeah your money is on
him as Champion eventually eventually I
don't think he beat Strickland the next
year no in the next year I my money's on
Strickland yeah two years because you
think stri Strickland can some stuff
take Downs no Strickland gets taken down
but I think he work back up to his feet
and I think hamzat dominates the first
and second round but then Strickland's
pressure in the third fourth and fifth
after seeing what Camaro did you have
some problems why Gilbert Burns did cuz
strickling does not stop he gets better
it's a it's a wave and if and hamza's
cardio hasn't been that Elite to me with
with Strickland he melts he breaks
everybody the toughest guys in the world
he breaks them so for Hamza that's a
nightmare dude 100% I'm very
intrigued I'm very intrigued are you
gonna bet on the Francis Fury fight yeah
I'm gonna put all I'm gonna put my house
on Tyson Fury you wouldn't make much
money right the bet would do bet that
Francis lands something sure I know a
little bit about how boxing Works what
at when you're fighting somebody who's
that level it's like I don't you know
it's impossible by at that level no I'm
saying I'm saying I'm saying I know a
little bit about what it's like to be a
guy who's new to boxing fighting a guy
who's been boxing his whole life real
hard to deal with real hard so you can
train with M Tyson as much even that no
that that level you you've never faced
anybody at that level I hav I'm saying
I'm saying that the way boxing works and
the reason they're really good at
predicting fights sometimes is they go
the people in the know go there's no way
you can catch up to this guy it'd be
like rolling J but he's not trying to
that but see that's the mistake the
common person thinks like oh he's just
going to outbox him Francis isn't go in
there and box him that he's not going to
box him he's going to flail he's GNA
when you remember how he fought roseno
when he was just like wild and you're
like what the [__] is this that's what
he has to do if he sits back and tries
to do it like a normal he's going to get
he's get his life changed the only way
work is in the first two rounds that's
what I said that's what he has to do
first two rounds are going to be Mayhem
you're you're and if it doesn't work
you're going to get annihilated all good
yeah the worst thing is for you to sit
back and try to outclass him and you're
you're you're life's going to change
forever not in a good way you're going
to go home speaking different which we
don't want so go out on your Shield home
or Simpson flail your arms if it lands
all good if not all good short night but
what we don't want to have happen is
whatever is 8 10 rounds and you get your
brains bashed in that's what we don't
want from a heavyweight who I think
regards the greatest heavyweight to ever
do it yeah probably yeah I mean you know
watching who beats
him I mean maybe George Foreman is prime
with that with how big he is maybe I
watch what he did to Dylan white I
watched what he did a lot of these big
big strong men and you know who''s been
boxing forever and if I'm Francis I just
go all right I fla my arms like it's
amateur well it's going to be also it's
very interesting because Francis will be
fighting somebody who's bigger than him
taller yeah yeah I mean chub yeah just
but but just wide hips just a lot to
manage and better footwork quicker knows
where to place he can't hit him is he
quicker you think oh yeah you mean his
hands his hands his footwork his
footwork
[Music]
yeah we've never seen anything like it
every wants to
be R Tyson Fury's footwork yeah not even
close and he's massive that's that's an
educated boxer who's been doing it
forever at the highest level has seen
all comers all comers Allan I literally
dude I just would I'm not even hitting
Ms for this kid and he's got he's got he
h every day every day four times a day
I'm coming in for 6
minutes you Bo a gold medalist who is
7et tall didn't you no never you boxed a
you you one of your training Partners
was a gold medalist in the Olympics oh
you're talking about guy oh yeah you did
you did you see me box him he want a
gold I remember you said to him though
you go if you knock me out I'm GNA take
you down yeah uh I forget his name he's
a a British boxer weird but then I also
went against D Williamson he was my
training partner for for a long time and
he was on the Olympic team with Floyd
and it was a nightmare how big was he 63
oh Jesus Christ on the Olympic team yeah
he's a Savage and and hitting and
hitting you in the head oh yeah me Shane
Nate just punching you guys right in the
face [__] you but I have a better shot
of beating him than Francis does Tyson
Fury because Tyson Fury would beat both
the gentlemen I fought in the same night
in one round that's how good he is those
are the odds against Francis yeah so C
box you got to do I'm telling you like a
street fight throw a knee just get in
there whatever [__] happens dude start
throwing and hopefully something
Falls you know yeah I mean it's going to
be fun you know you stupid [__] I like
just throw that in there dude you stupid
[__] you're a stupid [__] stupid [__]
idiot listen you [__] meat pie you
[__] idiot I flew first class so who
wins you D who
did well that's our show what's that
that's our show be take a little break
cuz I'm starving and I can't wait to get
home dude but my problem is I like to
cook at home but it takes so long I'm
talking hours dude I want toss together
rotisserie chicken you know me dude I'm
on that carnivore I need I'm sick of it
do you have anything I could use to make
it fast like meels under 30 minutes
everybody's got a crazy schedule all
right but at the end of the day when
Meal Time happens what if I gave you 40
recipes to choose from every week okay
so there's always something delicious I
say you're lying okay well hello fresh
would say I'm telling the truth okay you
got in seasoned ingredients you taste
all the freshness of fall in every bite
of hellofresh is Chef crafted
chef-crafted recipes all right they go
right from the farm to your door for
Peak ripeness so you can taste it okay
hellofresh does all the shopping and
meal planning for you what if I only
have 15 minutes Qui easy options problem
they got it they got you 15 M minute
meals that's they've got that for you
and I'm talking about if you tell me to
have barbecue pulled pork nachos I'm
going to bang you out oh yeah they got
they got that they got apple cider cake
they got with caramel sauce they got
mini pumpkin cheesecake they got all
kinds of stuff all right they take the
hassle out of Meal Time wow dude just go
to hellofresh.com
tfatk use the code 50 tfatk for 50% off
and free shipping it also 25%
hellofresh.com sl50
tfatk hellofresh America's number one
meal kit
25% less expensive than takeout that's
hellofresh.com promo code 50t fatk
America's number one meal kit well that
was a good recap of the weekend though
yeah had ourselves a civilized breakfast
at the Four Seasons I watched you eat
you didn't eat I don't eat breakfast huh
yeah you came down and you said you want
some I went n diet coke diet coke diet
coke my nicotine dude that's interesting
D cocoa black Buffalo you didn't eat
anything am think of it I E all day yeah
you didn't have literally I us don't eat
about two or three but then with the
time change and we're traveling I didn't
eat till I got
home I had two Twizzlers in the entire
day yeah that's my diet yeah got took a
ride in the uh felt sick I took a ride
in the cuck truck and uh what yeah it
would and it didn't work I got no I got
in turn on and it was it was that sound
too much for stepped on the accelerator
how did you feel I felt my back really
get swallowed in by the by the seat by
the torque my my back got swallowed by
the seat and uh and then I looked at
brenon and I go this car is every
14-year-old's
dream and it is I said I know I feel
like I'm in a frat that truck is so
ridiculous yeah oh we're not stopping
there Wednesday goes to Kibby Tech what
and then uh more stuff oh yeah we have
more stuff to do what else can be done
we got do we got to finish the episode
man what else are you doing all sorts of
stuff just tweaking making some tweaks
yep I'm
excited it's amazing Brandon would you
let Brian Drive Your Truck I couldn't
even finish the sentence you know what I
thought about driving it I was like
maybe a little spin no
cuz yeah well over a thousand but and
I'm even go up even more by the time I'm
done probably be around
1,300 such a how is that straight legal
and also why you think I'm worried about
the
rules think I give a
[__] I don't condone to these rules
these establishments it's your it's your
car come get me Nome you just drive that
everywhere everywhere yeah I'll pick my
kid up after school wake up they're all
taking naps I just wake them up with the
revving of the
engine wake up you little [__] dad's
Dad's
here it's like Jurassic Park the water
yeah yeah if if if we were still riding
horses back in the day You' you'd ride
up on a bull I got this bull I [__]
tamed it mod I modded this bull out
moded this bull
out I got a cup holder check out the
hoofs oh did you see that guy look up
Ryan Thomas backflip on a bike check
this out so this guy I think his name I
think his name is Ryan Thomas so he
um I think that's one time I tried a
back flip and a front flip this dude did
so so he goes suck right he jumps he
jumps we just just
the the bike goes this way but he goes
this way no way it's never been done
really yeah it's kind of cool oh like
the momentum like he's supposed to back
flip but he's going it's like it's it's
something that a yeah I watched this I
think it's Ryan Thomas maybe I'm wrong
but I think it is looks like let's just
give this a shot I guess yeah what's the
worst thing I know no this this one
this guy follows the shows yeah he's the
man but he's Master on scooters oh okay
and and bikes too he does bikes as well
he do well he said it
tooko what in the fu he's a professional
scooter guy and but he does bikes as
well that is so wild um this way you
want to show us no he did something
nobody's done
before we just need his name it would C
should we tell you bit killer all the
time yeah the momentum of the show just
yeah I did I saw a guy do a back flip on
a bik oh there it
is is this one look at
this come on he said he kept doing it
and he kept falling and kept like
nobody's ever done that like think about
practicing that ah I made a mistake he
said he said did it like a thousand
times before he got
it that now thousand there's a larger
point I'm making that's only dudes would
do that only guys I don't think there's
a woman on the planet no I I think
that's [__] I think that's what guys do
guys guys go I'm going to I'm going to
die trying something but you're only
doing that to impress other dudes or
you're just no girl do something nobody
else has done and be significant that's
kind
of like you got to be at the X Games
they do wild [__] like this all the they
really
do they do some crazy
[__] never had never had an interest in
that stuff yeah you brought it up yeah
well Ryan really I wonder if for it's
the same guy cuz it's Ryan Williams and
his Instagram is W yeah that's him yeah
and he's the one that did the front with
the back it must have been see oh d
That's will yeah so that's that's the
guy that follows the show yeah he's the
man he's got a tail piece
on know what you say and Chin doesn't
follow him yeah I don't follow X gam
stuff that's why yeah are they still
doing the X Games I'm pretty sure they
do it used to be big on ESPN too but
that's the flip right there right crazy
yeah he took some false he's super super
talented at yeah Sports yeah yeah super
freak yeah Lord have
mercy gotta work on my back flips all
right you any other videos you saw on
Tik Tok you want to tell us about no it
wasn't on Tik Tok oh I'm not on Tik Tok
I don't have the
app I don't [__] I've seen you scan
through I really don't actually did you
take it off easily no I just don't I
can't do it you're too old for it yeah
56 or whatever I can't and I don't even
go on Instagram anymore because the
problem is I'll you go oh let me see
this boxing thing or this Jiu-Jitsu
tutorial because I want to get better at
Jiu-Jitsu and then I you start scrolling
and 40 minutes later you're on a plane
going what the [__] wasted your life
yeah yeah yeah you don't have Instagram
on your phone right no
smart what what El current events yeah
all right so sonas yeah which one do we
want to go with let's go with this one
first the hip drop tackle thingy okay so
this is a Hot Topic in the NFL guys they
want to get rid of the hip drop tackle
um after last year Patrick Mahomes had
an injury Tony Pard had an injury and uh
they're calling it the cousin of the
horse caller what do you guys say how
are guys supposed to [__] tackle it's
football this stuff happens so there is
isn't there a thing where that happened
to grank where the guy done it to three
other players where he grabs grabs you
here slides and kind of like blocks your
knee and Falls they're just trying to
get you down the bite means necessary
like some guys like trust me they'd
rather just do it cleanly but these guys
are [__] big strong and fast and run
hard so they go down yes it's [__]
stupid it's football yeah I don't think
it's at all like a horse caller I mean
horse caller is literally grabbing your
shirt a holding call yes this to me is a
clean tackle this is to save your knees
right yeah that's what they're saying
cuz like Gino Smith got hurt this year
too because of it yeah but what are you
supposed to do it's also football it's
like yeah guys get hurt unfortunately
like how soft do we want to make
football it's like talking about banning
that you know the butt push with the
Philadelphia Eagles whenever it's Fourth
and inches they get really close and
then the running backs push homeboy's
butt so they get the first down anybody
can do it they're just the best at doing
it so they want to ban it they're like
it's cheating because they're they're
using you know behind momentum to push
them to the first down so you so stop it
then you guys stop it if if you want to
don't make it illegal just learn a way
to stop it yeah I don't know how you'd
stop this this this just
tackling it's just NFL getting
soft it feels like it's just it'd be
hard it's like they Bann you can't
tackle a guy by the dreads all right I
mean if somebody's running and you grab
them around the waist right and they
keep
running what are you supposed to do like
how are you supposed to now if you they'
banned this you're supposed to let go so
the guy
gets or he got yard and you've got to
stop him now and it changes the game
what are you supposed to do what are you
supposed to do like how do you all this
is the NFL trying to protect their
assets so like the quarterback rule all
right we can't have the most famous
person on the [__] field getting hurt
so that you can't touch the quarterback
basically now it's like flag football
yeah that was the Tom Brady rule they
call it because they protect their
assets this all right more if another
big time player gets hurt then they're
going to start looking at how to ban
that they're just trying to protect
their Investments that's all it is I I'm
not that mad at
it it's because you're [__] well besides
that yeah I'm not that mad at it get too
aggressive for me anyway they can save
somebody's KNE watch bang it out they
can save somebody's knee from an ACL
tear like that like groon don't play
football I know but that guy that guy
who did that to grank did it to another
player the game before there was a thing
he was doing like how do you avoid that
don't play football don't sign up for
football well no there's got to be a
better way you tell a guy not to tackle
when he's powerful yeah you went down to
the knees man what are we it's football
so what are they saying you can't grab
around the waist and go down to your
knee I don't know how they regulate that
I how I don't know how you stop and
putting too much you putting too much
power in the referees hands and they're
going to dictate like what's illegal and
those guys are
idiot yeah the issue is like the
Australian like rugby guys have already
gone ahead and like made this illegal
and but no one's come forward with an
actual proposal so that's the problem
people just
whining
MH okay well this leads into this
article here that just came out today um
so this guy named Kareem Jackson I'm not
sure if you guys are familiar with this
particular yeah so apparently he's had
like uh what they considered dirty shots
before and this one in particular was
really bad and he got kicked out of the
game he got ejected you know how much of
a b got to be to get kicked out for
Unnecessary R wait let me take the
volume off
they're saying here he dropped his
shoulder right there he
did yeah that was a little oness there
yeah he didn't have the ball but maybe
he didn't see it no he did have the ball
right no did he yeah but he goes yeah
his head but he didn't use his uh
because he hit the guy in the head but
he didn't spare him I don't know dude
but apparently he has like a history of
doing like you mean a history of laying
pipe dude yeah a history
history history of being a good [__]
defensive player I know listen I grew up
on hit him with his shoulder he didn't
it was a helmet to the no it's a
shoulder it's a good tackle I think
that's a I mean don't play football they
don't want you to drop your shoulder
anymore though Brian you can't hold on
let's see let's see
he's he could have easily like he's not
thinking that's right in his chest yeah
he's trying to stop him it's both the
head and should that's a [__] call
to me head and shoulders n no that's
[__] [__] I don't know what else
that's aash no no it's not the power is
all in the chest it's all all is
centered in the chest correct I don't
now if it was all head I get that if
he's just head hunting that's called a
good hit where else is he that's a good
hit that's a perfectly timed hit I think
maybe we're just old school so he's been
fined almost 90 grand so far this year
worth
it
yeah I mean does this up his cache or
what I don't know I don't know this
football I don't know this Sport and the
Broncos won this week I know that's a
big deal we
suck all right all right more on the
football so great signing great signing
fully condone this so H I guess this is
Kim Kardashian's uh line right it's
called skins so this for men and then
Nick Bosa who you guys love very much uh
I
guess ton of thirst tweets after he did
the promotion for it there's his body
right there with the Skins yeah he's
he's pretty trapped
out that boy is so funny I'm not even a
gay man but it's distracting today
you're into strong Jaws like what a
perfect signing though I'm wearing the
cotton tank yeah you are yeah you are
what that dick do am right mind mostly
just envisioning how I could execute
I'll tell you who Brian wants to bang
out with Brian just constantly just like
Brian's Jaws open well cuz all I want to
be is that I want to look like that
what's he weigh size doesn't always
you're closer to Francis andano they are
him yeah better athlete than
Nano not even close get out my great
product by the way skims people love
skims yeah that's why sk's a billionaire
great product you know Kanye owns a huge
Is that real he's 267 really he's every
bit of 270 64 27 fre W tosses brenon
around brenan's like this come on he
tickles brenon comes in like this hey
come here you and brendon's like come on
and you'd be in the back going you bang
it out and he'd go don't say
that bang it out hey big boy come over
here he's like no come on don't I just
bought this shirt I know it's all
colorful yeah we'd have a good time big
old thick fingers bang it
out what a great signing though that
Markin team knows their stuff we're not
the only ones who like them
correct they got be paying him a pretty
penny yeah for sure yeah um heavy on the
pretty SAS yeah well luckily this wasn't
your flight guys but an off-duty pilot
for Alaska is going to be charged with
83 counts of attempted murder I always
hope this happens on my plane CU he
tried to pull the engine yeah I would
love if someone did this on my plane
just use my skill set I would love just
to be a hero on the his off oh just like
I'll handle this so an all pilot riding
as a passenger in the
cockpit Tred to seize control the plane
that is crazy why dude 83 counts of
reckless endangerment he's
screwed what happened here we've got the
guy that tried to shut the engines down
out of the cockpit he doesn't sound like
he's causing any issues in the back
right
now uh I think he's subdued other than
that we want law enforcement as soon as
we get on the ground for whatever reason
he wanted to shut off the engines and he
was a pilot and he knew how yeah that's
the scary part that is very weird
probably just maybe he's on shrooms like
you were yeah maybe his mind was
hijacked by some foreign intelligence
agency you g him too much credit I think
he just panicked and was like had an
episode I was like I got to shut this
thing down episode I'm gonna kill
everybody board that's was he oh they
were in the air yes he's trying to shut
the engines down yes oh yeah we got to
kill them I mean yeah it's
weird like that yeah kill him you you
just go into the cockpit hey
hey is he all right yeah I killed him
what yeah I killed what I killed him I
would love to see what each of you would
do in that situation well oh Brian be in
the back sucking his thumb while he goes
go get him Bren no I wouldn't yeah yeah
Brian would direct crowd look and then
went over Bri go anybody have any penis
if I was on mushrooms I'd be like I
can't if I was on mushrooms I had to
just I'll be here with my popcorn get
them I'll be here with my popcorn get
them Brandon did you get them get
him it's too much for me no go Crush
Brian be like you got this why you got
this you know what you're going to do
you go what you go entertain the women
and children while I take care of
Daddy's work is that that's what I would
do yeah all right hey guys who likes a
puppet show and then then you'd yell in
the back bang him out brendon's gonna be
banging out the uh terrorist in the
front is he labeled a terrorist
I believe I would go I would go in there
and uh I'd cause some
problems I've been doing a lot of uh as
you know studying of Jiu-Jitsu online
you could show it off what else you got
CH throw in the old that guy goes away
for how
long I mean 83 counts of felony like
this F forever yeah a week 8 yeah 83
yeah yeah
yeah who knows I don't know
all right give me a sec here this is a
uh this is in Russia unfortunately this
is a Russian
teacher with her student and the sewage
pipe blew up right behind them no please
I don't know how this happened like the
the timing oh [__] please yeah oh no
let me play the video real quick he's
been and it's it's the waste pipe so
it's there's crap in there yeah do it
just comes flying out you'll see in a
second El they're all laughing in the
back this is the last thing
oh yeah that was pretty bad she leaned
into it oh yeah I mean they had no idea
the kid got the worst of it though cuz
it's all on his back and his laptop too
his laptop's going to be destroyed she
kind of she got out of the way kind of
like she's all listen I went boom that
someone in her mouth 100% yeah without a
doubt it's doooo baby that is not good
dude okay so this video went viral have
you guys seen this at all first of all
any you have I haven't seen this what is
so she's pretty she is pretty she she's
actually pretty hot uh she dat dashed
after she St 48 oysters that's $4,000 D
she why she going so bad left is that
her that's her yeah and he just got up
and laugh was like
oh I this [__] I met a few week it's
kind of a longer video but it's worth it
I think been texting me for weeks
talking to his why I didn't block him
[__] I don't know but today I was bored
and I had time so he text me like can we
meet for drinks and I'm like yeah meet
me here got the best [__]
o so the guy wanted to take like $75 in
oysters
she seems like uh I I enjoy good oysters
just like she's baking them too yeah
that's good
oysters she sleping her but 48 oysters
can you imagine 48 and there are some
small ones for sure he's like you want
another
one she's got good manners at
least and she even said like this is
good content to like you know film what
a crazy woman and then she just left him
there with the no no no no no he left
her you looking at me crazy I don't give
a [__] I'm you invited me out I'mma eat
she kind of sucked though she literally
just went to use them for the oysters
all it but I did do all it I was so good
I was not expecting to you're not that
interesting she's left with the bill she
just did it for the content that's well
part of it was for so hold on that's got
to be at least 200 bucksy no it's a
dozen for 15 bucks what 75 bucks so she
ate more crab cakes and potatoes crab
cakes everything was so good 10 10 baby
why the [__] this [__] ass [__] say he
going to the bathroom come
back [__] yeah I'm like how the [__] on
it's been like 10 20 30 minutes [__]
where the [__] this [__] at had to end
up grabbing a tab [__] left me with his
little one [__] drink yeah [__] I'm
so glad [__] keep me some money cuz
what that was crazy to me me and I said
[__] you run out of the T he talk so
wait did you see that he said I cat up
you yeah he's like you ordered so much
food I said I don't want to take you out
for drinks only she's awful she Terri
terrible person but she is pretty hot
though I hate people who think well
she's I will give her 70 oysters she
eats a lot she eats a lot that's not
first date etiquette though no it's not
you don't go that hard she sucks I mean
she sucks but I can understand why the
guy was like but then he was like you no
no so you're just doing for content
she's not therez trying to connect with
the homeboy yeah no no she probably [__]
her pants when she got home probably
[__] four dozen oysters with all that
[__] on it Y and she washed it down
with crabcakes and a margarita dude
she's 100% [__] her
pants that's the other thing he's like I
don't want to deal with
this yeah she's uh yeah anyway she's
awful she's awful awful it's like you're
just a shitty person that's why you
dipped yeah you just suck sometimes
you're like what am I doing with my life
I can't be with this person well on a
third order he's like oh yeah you're aw
yeah and you're eating potatoes and crab
cakes and filming it while you're on a
date with
me and going like this but 48 oysters is
so these are so good I'm like all they
got the best oysters like get the [__] I
can't even get one
down great sick though it's easy get
sick from the wrong oyster you just
we've been sick you me and Jay have been
sick from an oyster place I forgot in
one of the tours oh that's right went to
in Vegas we went to a sushi place and I
tasted one bite and I went this is not
good I remember that I don't eat sushi I
was sick for four months yeah what is
this some I found this on uh Lacrosse
Network this is a
1932 brawl at a lacrosse game just
whites yeah
just all guys fighting away just hitting
each other with sticks so it was pretty
crazy back hit him on the back of the
head yeah that a penalty or but then
they they reposted Brennan's post the
international lacrosse thing oh
wow look at that what say pretty cool
certified lacrosse guy you you had a
pretty crooked face there buddy hey
crooked look at that yeah you just what
do you mean I don't know your face looks
all not that symmetrical there buddy
old school that's a stud right old
school long hair just whatever there you
go there you go there it is hey you were
a
cutie yeah I love lacrosse
man love I don't mind you with a shav
head look good I mind you with a shave
head I look
good it's getting tough dude right no
I'm goodlooking I'm a good-looking man
an older your face yeah not your hair no
even my like your face is whatever but
your hair is somebody said I look like a
Russian wrestler and I said can you
repeat that please let me get my hand on
my pants I said you look like a Russian
wrest no your hair is a disaster but
your face is cool at your always been a
dister always been since I've known you
your hair's never been since I was a kid
I've never had good hair even as a kid
even as a kid and I'm not kidding I
never had good hair it was thin and fall
sucked it just was no it just sucked it
was frizzy and shitty and it just
sucked I'm crying yeah some problems top
of your head looks like a globe don't
say that what dude like the hair's like
continent no I don't like that no no
don't say it looks like a globe okay
right listen no no no listen there's
some things I draw the line on I got to
get a magic
mind guys you know what no matter what
happens what doesn't help when your
friend [__] insults you you always
have magic mind and that creates an
alertness you have that going for you
get into the flow and you realize that
it's all good baby it's going to be my
third one of the day yeah that's what
happens dude do you think if I drink
this I'll look like the owner um no
that's uh they're both dimes you dumb
asses James James James James just shot
me and he has a party on Thursday can
you come to that absolutely not but we
should go I'm telling you his parties
are great go I do my dad my dad's coming
in town yeah but he's so great you we we
need to have dinner with James always a
great time I know I do want to go the
best he's the best where's it is it in
Malibu they're coming up well I I don't
know if I'm allowed to say this but I
think they're coming up with a sparkly
magic mine an you know I'm glad there
cuz I always went man wish was more
Sparkle in this I know I want more
Sparkle and I want bigger I want you
mean like um like a drink like a Celsius
or something oh like sparkling water but
sparkling oh that'd be cool
yeah I love
this all right what else you got J
mental Clarity decreases
stress gets you in a flow state try it
try it I don't know anyone who's taken
these and didn't love them it's true
they're really good the bottle makes me
happy do more stress less Little Wave on
there I like magic mind as a
name they're doing really well by the
way I'll throw it away for
you what do you got Jen I think that's
pretty much it is that it for current RS
yeah no more skims
ads no more skim ads no more uh nigar
Falls November 3rd and 4th almost sold
out one show Friday one show Saturday
November 3rd and 4th basically Buffalo
coming out Buffalo show some support for
your former Buffalo Bill I was on the
team for three minutes come on out
Niagara Falls Bassy Buffalo November 3rd
and 4th Chicago December 8th and 9th
downtown Chicago that's two shows Friday
two shows Saturday then we just
announced the keep trucking what I
forget don't put me on the spot we just
announced way to go B we just announced
the keep trucking t starts 2024 at
Nashville January 25th that's a Thursday
then Austin January 26th 27th ticket at
bigboy.com all the automotive content uh
Toontown will drop very soon I'm
finished up at kib Tech Wednesday we'll
have some announcements as far as the
car content
goes uh this weekend guys Friday
Saturday Chicago improv Friday October
27th Saturday October 28th Raleigh North
Carolina I'll see you November 9 10 and
11 and then yuck yucks in Calgary back
Yu a good club I haven't been in a hot
I've been in Calgary and haven't been in
yuck great there November 16 17 and 18 I
can't wait it's been a long time Canada
I'm coming back I'm coming back Canada
November 16 1718 God bless everybody